- Good afternoon everybody.
You are very welcome here.
I'm Steph Newell from the
English Department here at Yale.
It's my greatest pleasure to introduce
our distinguished speaker this evening,
the Nobel Laureate
Professor Abdulrazak Gurnah.
Let me start with some thanks
to our sponsors and organizers.
Professor Gurnah's visit to
Yale has been made possible
by generous funding from the
Council on African Studies
at the Yale MacMillan Center
as well as the Trumbull
Endowed Lecture Fund,
the Whitney Humanities Center,
the office of the Dean of Humanities
and the English Department.
Meanwhile, over several months
and with meticulous attention
to detail, Cristin Siebert
and Mariwa Kabor of the
Council on African Studies
and the Yale MacMillan Center
have organized everything
for Professor Gurnah's visit
from transportation to venues
to food to drink to much, much more.
So Cristin and Mariwa wherever you are,
there they are at the back,
please, let's say thank you to them
for all of their organizations.
(audience applauding)
So our preparations have been supported
all along the way
by the Director of the
Whitney Humanities Center,
Professor Alice Kaplan
and the Associate Director
Diane Barrett Brown.
And thanks also go to the chair
of the English department,
Mark Robinson, the Chair of
the Council on African Studies,
Professor Cajetan Iheka,
and the Dean of Humanities,
Professor Katie Laughton.
And they've all been very supportive,
and we are also grateful to Jen Castellon
and Michael Morand at
the Beinecke Library,
and you are all very warmly
invited after this lecture
to the Beinecke Library for a
reception and a musical treat.
We're also very grateful
to the student helpers
who are here to help out this afternoon.
So now, as you may have
gathered as you came in,
your presence at this venue
is an indication of your
consent to the recording
that we are making of
Professor Gurnah's lecture.
So we'll have time for
a short Q&A after this.
But by putting your hands up
and receiving the microphone,
you are also implicitly agreeing,
consenting to being recorded.
We've also got a book stall outside
which you may have seen on your way in.
You're very welcome to buy copies of books
and Professor Gurnah has very
kindly agreed to sign books
after the lecture for a
very short period of time.
So welcome, welcome to you.
And now when Abdulrazak
Gurnah was named winner
of the Nobel Prize for literature in 2021,
his publishers were caught off guard
by the overnight upsurge
in demand of his novels.
And for a brief period as
supply caught up with demand,
printed copies of his works
vanished from the shelves.
Bookshops struggled to restock,
and the New York Times
complained in a headline
he won the Nobel.
Why are his books so hard to find?
(audience laughing)
Meanwhile, the reaction
of literary scholars
to Professor Gurnah's Nobel
Prize was a noisy, "Of course!"
As the Sudanese British
author Leila Aboulela put it,
she says "Now our well kept
secret is out in the open."
For more than three decades,
Professor Gurnah has been
an influential figure
among post-colonial literary scholars.
He's the author of 10 novels,
numerous short stories,
academic books, reflective
essays and scholarly articles.
And as Professor of Literature
at the University of Canterbury,
his work has helped to shape our field.
So when literary scholars think
about the oceanic histories
of East Africa, for
example, and those old,
the old Spice routes
connecting Zanzibar with India
and the Arab world
or when they think about the experiences
of different kinds of migrants from Africa
to the global north,
they turn to his fiction.
From the outset with the
publication of his first novel
"Memory of Departure" in 1987
Professor Gurnah has
focused on ordinary people
caught up in momentous
events in East Africa.
So they're often set in
Zanzibar where he was born
but also in the neighboring
countries of Tanzania and Kenya.
His novels feature characters
whose lives are impacted
by war, colonialism, decolonization,
but often who have little control
over the events that shape their world.
What horizons open and close, he asks,
in the lives of ordinary Africans,
when they coincide
with these seismic
political transformations
on the continent that
are beyond their control.
How do they navigate
through violent events
like European colonialism,
world wars, fascism,
displacement, revolutionary
post-colonial conflict?
In his Nobel Prize lecture,
Professor Gurnah describes
his creative writing
as retrieving stories, and again and again
you can see this process of
retrieval in his fiction.
Whether it's an old man on his deathbed
with a secret to disclose to his family
as in "The Last Gift"
or a young man who
escapes domestic slavery
into another form of servitude
in the East African German
army in the First World War
as that's in his most
recent novel "Afterlives,"
his work focuses on the figures
whose experiences and
feelings are either absent
from the written archives
or so thoroughly overwritten
by colonial racial categories
that their subjective
experiences can't be recomposed
from the historical record.
As the narrator puts it in "Afterlives,"
"East Africa has simply been a sideshow
"to the great tragedies in Europe."
In Professor Gurnah's fiction
you do not find a comfortable
retrieval of stories
into visibility.
Many of his characters
experience false memories
or sometimes their lies take on substance
and become part of their family history.
Or new memories displace old ones
or stories become riddled with doubt,
but complicated as the
stories and memories
of his characters are,
as their lives unfold in each novel,
we see tangled accounts
giving way to confessions,
confusion and evasion
giving way to clarification.
Time and again in his novels,
histories are corrected.
Memories are set right.
While you find many
different kinds of narrator
in Professor Gurnah's novels,
but you also find many different scenes
of listening and examples of listeners
as stories are told and retold.
The way people and their
stories are received
is vital to his work.
A failure to listen is shown
to be another form of violence.
"You cannot imagine what
that time was like,"
says the mother of the
narrator of "Gravel Heart"
as she tries yet again
to describe the trauma of
the January 1964 revolution
in Zanzibar.
"You cannot imagine the terror of it,
"the arrests, the
deaths, the humiliations.
"People were driving each other mad
"with rumors of new outrages, new decrees
"with news of further sorrows.
"But yes, you can imagine you must try.
"Nothing stands between us
and atrocities but words.
"So there is no choice
but to try and imagine.
"If you stop trying to tell your story,"
she continues, "after a while,
"it becomes as if these
things did not really happen,
"did not really happen like that,
"as if you're exaggerating
if you speak of them.
"So you stop speaking,
"and they recede even further away.
"They become even more unreal
"become even less possible to imagine,
"and you tell yourself
it's time to move on.
"Let them go.
"It's not worth the bother of remembering.
"But they do not let you go."
Like the listeners inside his
stories, Abdulrazak Gurnah
calls on us as readers,
as listeners to imagine
and in so doing to inhabit and remember
the lives of his characters.
Tonight's lecture is
called "Writing Memory."
Please welcome Professor
Abdulrazak Gurnah.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much.
Thank you, Steph.
Thank you.
That was a wonderful introduction.
I couldn't have asked you better,
and thank you all for being here.
I'm very happy to be here
and to answer the question
that I'm sure you're burning
to get an answer to is
yes, it's the first
time I'm coming to Yale.
(audience laughing)
But it seems to be wherever you go,
people say is this the
first time you're here?
So you know, I like to
get this out of the way
as soon as possible.
So yes it is.
Yes it's good to be here.
It's been relatively
nice. (audience laughing)
A lot nicer than where
we've come from in the UK.
Anyway, really Steph, thank you very much
for that introduction, that appreciation.
I've already met some of you.
I met some of you yesterday.
Some of the students yesterday,
and I know and have
heard already from you.
So glad to see you again.
Okay, so it's always interesting
when you are invited to give a lecture,
say a year before the
lecture is due to be given.
And so we said, all right, what
are you going to talk about?
And you know, nothing's
further away from your thoughts
than this event that's
gonna happen a year hence.
But I knew that this idea,
this topic of memory,
this, it's something
that I think about a lot
and talk about and write about.
So I thought this would be something
that it might be interesting
to put some ideas together
and see what comes out.
So for a writer or at least
for a writer of a certain kind,
a writer like, I mean in that respect,
not the person, but the
kind of writing I do.
So for a writer of that kind,
the kind I'm familiar with,
memory is a vital resource.
I'm not referring to
the ability to remember
when I say memory, to remember
certain facts or details,
but I'm referring to the swamp of memories
that linger on long after
the moment has passed
and which at times strike out of silence
to leave one quivering with sorrow,
and if one is lucky
with unexpected elation.
I think of this idea of memory,
this idea of memory is not facts
or not remembered things exactly,
but this kind of, I call it
swamp, but you know what I mean.
This kind of indefinable thing
that lurks all the time there
and every now and again
surfaces and catches you.
I think of this idea of memory
as a writer's hinterland
in the sense that,
hinterland in the sense
that large urban centers
depend on the country around them
to provide the means to sustain them.
I used this word to describe memory,
and somebody says why do you
want to use a German word?
I said, no, no, no.
Hinterland is not a German word.
Didn't you do all level
geography or something like that.
But another way of speaking,
the hinterland in the sense of
it provides the source material,
the place where the
writer goes back to for,
to kind of check the plausibility
of certain notions and ideas
and that sort of thing.
But another way of speaking about memory
is to describe it as experience.
We remember what we have experienced,
and we do so in a profound
sense of that word experience.
Now there may be events,
experience may be events
which befell us in person
or stories we heard about
other people in other places
or news or histories we read about
or dreams and imaginings
that thrilled, excuse me,
that thrilled or baffled us.
I think of experience
as all of those things.
This is what goes on in our consciousness.
Both because we live it,
because we hear about it,
because we read about it or
in other ways we imagine it.
We anticipate it because
of what we already know.
It's the writer's self-inflicted burden
to make something engaging,
productive, or even beautiful
out of this.
The recall of memory in writing
performs several of these functions
that I've been touching on.
It engages the recording of
memory in writing engages
by evoking salient details.
It makes the engagement productive
because we believe in it.
We find it plausible
and we hear echos of it
in our own knowledge.
There's all this lovely moment
when you're reading something
and you're kind of without being aware,
and you're nodding because you think
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes
because we're hearing something
that is both persuasive
but also because we recognize something.
And if the writer has been blessed
with the ability and insight,
the product is even beautiful.
So you not only nod and say that,
but you think, oh gosh, that's good.
How did he do that?
(audience laughing)
We read for comparably complex ends.
There is pleasure in
the engagement itself.
I would've thought that's
probably the primary part
of the experience of reading.
It doesn't work if there isn't that.
So there is pleasure in the engagement
which is difficult to describe
but which is palpable,
which is something we
can feel when we feel it.
That pleasure it seems to
me is as I just mentioned,
primary, unless of course
if we're in the midst of our
university literature program.
(audience laughing)
We see our inclinations
and ideas expressed
more persuasively than we are
capable of doing ourselves.
We're exposed to places and
times and ways of thinking,
some of which are familiar and
some completely unfamiliar.
In other words, in addition
to the pleasure of reading
something beautifully
or powerfully expressed,
we also receive news.
We learn.
The least of these functions
that I've been trying to
summarize is if you like,
why do we read or what
do we get outta reading?
The list of these functions,
which the recall of
memory in writing performs
is to evoke nostalgia for a lost time,
to speak a lament for a contentment
which is no longer possible.
Nostalgia in this sense
would seem to refer
to a kind of self-deception,
an introspective desire
to see what is passed more positively
than the present state.
And as scholars and
students of literature,
we are often skeptical of such tropes.
Indeed, we are trained to be skeptical,
and there are good reasons for this
both in reading literature
and in living our lives
because at worst, sentiment
can also be a means of evasion,
a refusal to acknowledge responsibility
for what was done in our name.
On the other hand, let's not be in a hurry
to throw out this word nostalgia.
You can find this out by
just checking on Google.
The word nostalgia derives
from the Greek words
nostos, which means return
and algos, which means pain.
And one of its meanings is the distress
aroused by a yearning for
one's place of origin.
It's a yearning that those who have lost
their places of origin,
have lost their homes,
know only too well.
In recent times, we have witnessed
a strange panic in Europe
about the arrival of what
are described as refugees.
You are familiar with that
panic in this country as well,
but I'll restrict my remarks to Europe
in order to avoid homogenizing
complicated issues,
which is one of the problems
of the representation
of people on the move.
It has become common to
refer to all arrivals
from outside of Europe as refugees,
when perhaps more nuanced
terms would enable us
to see the phenomenon of displacement
and migration more clearly.
The use of this word
in reference to the population upheavals
of non-European people
is inflected with criminal
and malicious intention
and subsequent social jeopardy
for the destination country.
More often than not, it is
emptied of the threat to life
and the desperate distress
that prompted the flight
in the first place.
Refugees are not a new
phenomenon for Europe
or for anywhere else in the world,
but for Europe which has been
convulsed in relentless wars
on its own soil for centuries,
it's even less of an unknown phenomenon.
These movements were
not only within Europe,
but large ones to north and South America,
the victims of economic and
social distress on the move.
Even larger numbers of
Europeans went or were sent
to what we now call the global south.
These were not refugees or
they were not all refugees,
but people empowered
at times involuntarily
by the expansionist
ideologies of their states
to displace and dispossess
non-European people
of their rights and their
lands and at times their lives,
and to call this process
a civilizing mission.
The incredible destruction
of the 20th century wars
saw not only the pulverization
of prosperous and densely
populated cities and territories,
but an unprecedented
forced transfer of people.
What else is the refugee
but a creature on the move
as a result of such circumstances?
When we speak of such a figure,
we should remind ourselves
that the European colonization
of the continents was also a deprivation
of the rights and lands of native peoples,
some of whom now have no recourse
but to seek the safety and prosperity
which their oppression has produced.
How should we begin to think
about the human obligation
in this phenomenon?
What are we to do?
To me, it seems both a
moral and human obligation
to offer hospitality
to people whose lives are at risk
and indeed to avoid
criminalizing a desire for safety
and self-fulfillment.
I began by speaking about
memory as a vital resource
of a certain kind of writer or
for a certain kind of writer.
And I'll return to that presently
in the light of the representation
and the self-representation
of the displaced figure.
Recently in my tour of the world,
the reason I was asked to
speak in the same way like this
like I mentioned at the
beginning, will you give,
actually I wasn't even asked.
I was told.
You are giving the inaugural address
in about two hours and
your topic is like that.
It happens honestly, but
this time my topic was
writing as a form of resistance.
Talk about that.
(audience laughing)
My first instinct was to resist
because I thought this was one
of those platform statements
or overstatements.
Literature is the meaning of life,
that kind of self-congratulation
that commentators
and practitioners of the writing business
are sometimes prone to.
But I had to speak to
people to whom this subject
had already been announced,
so there was no escape.
So I rephrased the topic for myself.
If writing is a form of resistance,
what is it resistant to?
In the first place I think
resistance to forgetfulness.
What oppressions and
tragedies befall people
at the hands of powerful forces
and what is known and believed
in can no longer be known
and believed in in the same way,
the compulsion is to move on,
to get on with it, to forget,
precisely the passage you quoted,
although I didn't know
you were going to do that.
It's a compulsion endorsed
by those responsible for such events.
Who would prefer that we do forget
that we do not remember what
led to our present state.
A few years ago, a British Prime Minister
on a visit to Tanzania was
exasperated by a question
about colonialism,
and he was reported to reply,
"Why are you talking about colonialism?
"It's over.
"Forget about it and let's move on."
It was Gordon Brown actually.
Our own governments would
also like us to forget
about their atrocities too and move on.
And in many instances,
citizens have no choice
but to do so in order to
preserve life and decency,
but writers do have a choice.
They can choose not to
allow what they know
and what they remember
to pass away unnoticed.
Writing is not only about
noble and brave ideas and acts.
It is not necessarily
about fighting tyrants
or necessarily about standing on platforms
and making powerful
speeches to energize people.
It's about the ordinary, mundane business
of keeping alive what is important,
which is about how
people imagine themselves
and how they see and describe
the world they live in.
In an important way,
I think there is a kind
of responsibility in that.
Writing is resistance to distortion
by narratives that seek
to justify injustice,
to distract us from what our
mind should be focusing on,
to draw us to other things
that might appear at first more appealing
or more interesting or more immediate.
It is resistance, in
other words, to neglect.
And it is important to
continue to uphold those ideas
and beliefs that we think are
important and that we value.
You get the picture, I hope,
it's about remembering.
A while ago I referred to the way
recollections of a lost time
are taken to be sentimental
and suspect and nostalgia.
I suggested that we hang onto that word,
at least in his sense of the distress
aroused by yearning for
one place of origin.
I said earlier that it is a yearning
of those who have lost their
homes know only too well.
Towards the end of his
memoir, "Out of Place,"
Edward Said says, I quote,
"To this day I feel that I am,"
Sorry, since I'm quoting, I
want to it exactly right, huh?
"To this day I still feel
that I'm away from home."
I would like to dwell on that for a moment
on what constitutes the ongoing
memory of what has been lost
and how some writers have coped with that.
Said has written in a variety
of ways about that experience.
Nuruddin Farah, the eminent Somali writer,
has only ever written about
Somalia in his 11 novels,
even though he has not lived in Somalia
for any length of time since 1970.
I'm concentrating mainly on writers from,
shall we say the global south,
because one can think of others
as well, Joyce, for example,
Nabokov for another example.
But anyway, let's stay with our community.
In his brilliant early
poems, Kamau Brathwaite
has the figure of the
itinerant Caribbean man
whom he describes thus
in the poem "Folk Ways,"
"Ever see a man travel
more, see more lands
"than this poor landless
harborless spade?"
Brathwaite poses that as a question,
ever seen anyone like him?
He poses that as a question in a way,
and in a way it was true to his own life,
which is spent largely away
from his home island Barbados.
But he always wrote about the Caribbean,
and he returned there in his
last days to live and die.
"Cow Pastor" Christ Church, Barbados.
The places he described, I quote,
"my maroon town, resistance palenque."
Palenque is the ancient Mayan
city in southern Mexico,
and it's invocation with reference
to Cow Pastor, cow pasture,
okay, we're getting both.
This is typical Brathwaite,
you know, the slash, you know?
It's this, it's that.
So it's sometimes cow pastor
sometimes it's cow pasture.
But the invocation of
the reference to Palenque
with reference to cow pastor/cow pasture
is part of Brathwaite's lifelong
idea of a new world vision
for the Caribbean, a
vision whose force derived
from an embrace and
imaginative transformation
of the Caribbean, the tragic
history of the Caribbean,
of slavery and plantation.
Derek Walcott in "Schooner
Flights" has his Shabine
utter the famous lines
celebrating Caribbean diversity.
I quote, "Either I'm
nobody or I'm a nation."
Before, later on, enabling that diversity
by casting the Caribbean
man as a Homeric hero
in search of his place in the world.
The Guyanese novelist Wilson Harris
set all of his 22 novels in Guyana,
even though he lived most of
his adult life in Colchester
just outside London.
And of course Jean Rhys, who in her 60s
returned to the Dominica of her childhood
to write "Wide Sargasso Sea."
So what is it about place
that has this incredible grip
on the writer's imagination?
What is it that makes it
so difficult to give up
the force of its memory.
Isn't one place as good
as another in the end?
The causes of the impulse to disperse,
to leave home often have similar sources,
an injustice, terror, disgust or need.
And while refugee appears to be a word
with a firm and clear
idea of its reference,
it includes the terrified Rohingya child
and the young African man
recklessly risking everything
for a life in Europe.
It includes the religious persecuted
and the victims of war
and imperial aggression.
I think that what makes
it impossible to give up
this memory of place is
an unredeemed injustice
and unappeased longing
where to abandon an
obligation to place and people
seems like treachery.
However, ineffectual and self tormenting
such memorializing might seem
to a practical minded person,
the impulse to do so is unavoidable
because to do otherwise, to forget
would seem like self-indulgent neglect.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)